was it hard to get the managed to get
live yeah kind of just documents i mean
i guess you've you've lived in japan so
maybe getting documents for stuff is
like easy mode yeah it's like it's it's
actually uh i mean
it's
harder to get the documents and now that
we live outside of japan because
originally we wanted a church wedding
and the more we looked into it the
[ __ ] the the harder it was mostly
because uh one you know i'm not
christian it's only sydney
um and also a lot of churches in the uk
are very strict about who they allow to
get married there or like the priest so
a lot of the times you need to be like a
regular at the church and if you're not
already have attended like when you're a
kid or a regular or your family goes
there then you need to attend for like
you know like a month or something just
so just so the priest knows you and now
that just wasn't an option for us
because you know it's it's hard enough
taking a two-week holiday but away from
the boys you know i mean i couldn't just
go back to be like guys i gotta attend
church
i gotta see the lord so yeah um
unfortunately we couldn't get a church
wedding but you know that's all fine we
can still
it's everything is all ready now legally
we are you know we've booked the place
we booked the registrar decided to go i
am so excited to go i'm so excited for
you boys to go as well all you can eat
right huh or you can eat right i heard
yeah yeah yeah right yeah
i won't i won't spoil everything that we
have planned
before the wedding my only question is
there food
that's all i need to know there is there
is food yeah yeah aside from like
planning my own wedding i actually also
was able to attend a friend's wedding
while i was back as well it was a very
very packed
very very packed trip for me i literally
uh attended this wedding and then the
day after i flew back to japan to uh
meet uh
meet uh the other boys i guess and the
other boys
my other spouses as a city says
my boyfriend yeah yeah and like it was
so surreal because it was the first
mates wedding i've been to and it was so
surreal because a lot of weddings now um
have been delayed to this year because
obviously we've covered and everything
that's that includes me so this what
this year is just [ __ ] packed for
weddings like i think you're you're on a
three you're going to three wins this
year aren't you i'm going to yours i'm
going to my friends in ireland and then
i'm going to my cousins in japan yeah
yeah and all of them have were supposed
to happen like two years ago yeah yeah
exactly all this year yeah so a lot of
weddings have been postponed to this
year so i basically just got like like i
basically got to see
what a wedding is going to be like and
like you know seeing my mate get married
and everything and seeing everything
from the audience perspective before uh
before i up there standing up there
myself you did the beta test i did the
beta test right
this is pretty good i think we can go
forward soon yeah i'll be honest man i
was [ __ ] nervous as [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
like it was it was someone else's
wedding yeah someone else right right
because because it's like uh i've i've
known this guy for like almost as long
as i've known sydney right so
um i remember just
being in the audience and seeing him
stand up there and waiting for the bride
to come out um just seeing him try to
keep it together just like made me like
think [ __ ] man like i'm feeling your
nerves right now because i know
everything he's like going through and
i'm just like this is going to be me in
a month
i i thought to myself [ __ ] if i'm this
nervous
in the crowd how am i going to be
when i'm up there like when when i'm up
there guys
this could be an element of stage fright
right because you have to like do
something in front of all your friends
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was it was actually so funny though
because uh
it was like we were waiting in the venue
where
uh where all the family was and the
groom was up there on stage with um
uh with the wedding party and everything
and you know we had like this beautiful
heart playing and everyone was like
silence and then there was just like
this the small pause right as the
harpist was like changing to the next
song uh the bride was already like was
was already like uh i believe five to
ten minutes after you know the ceremony
had already been scheduled to happen so
you know we
we weren't nervous but it was just like
tense you know you could like you could
cut the tension with a knife everyone
was everyone wasn't talking and then
there was this brief silence um and then
out of nowhere
um because sydney was like one of the
bridesmaids right out of out of nowhere
we just hear
in the corner like just someone going
yes girl
yes
oh god
and and that just like and and that just
everyone just like started laughing like
the tension was gone for just like
tension was just like instantly gone
give whoever said that a metal play
but no it was uh it was yeah it was it
was
it's it's weird attending a mate's
wedding
i'm i'm curious
i'm curious to see how you guys react as
well because for me like i was just
after it was over it's just such a nice
feeling it was like the most like
like every cliche you could imagine but
it's like cliche in a nice way because
it's it's it's how everyone describes
being at a wedding but like you're just
drunk on positive vibes you know you're
just like you was you're just so happy
for
uh for the couple and the future and the
bride in the groom and just seeing them
tie the knot and just
seeing them go through all that after
you know both of them and after you've
seen them like you know build up their
relationship it's just such a weird
moment to see just just to see
everything culminate into this one
awesome moment and it's just awesome
it's just so wholesome it's so wholesome
oh god i was just i'm still like i'm
still like glowing from like positive
vibes from that event i'm just like damn
man i can't i can't wait i can't wait i
can't wait
i'm hyped i'm very quiet
interesting because it's like my friends
in japan and my friends in the uk are
going to see each other yeah so the same
thing for you it's gonna be strange yeah
yeah yeah because we i was on the corner
earlier where you know mostly it's like
for a lot of people it's just going to
be our japan lot and
our
uk friends meeting for the first time
and connor's the only one who is kind of
like got you know
bridging bridging between everyone you
know he knows everyone basically it's
gonna be interesting yeah because you
know normally you when your friends
groups live in other countries they
don't normally interact with each other
yeah it's gonna be really interesting
yeah
actually one of the funnest parts of the
wedding planning because we've been
doing like a lot of wedding planning
some of it
you know some of it's stressful some of
it not but like by far the most funnest
point uh is i get to choose who sits
next to each other in
puzzle level difficulties
yeah so we're so a lot of like some
wedding some winning parties you know
they they do like a like a soft
segregation between you know that
and it it it is what it feels like
discrimination is always necessary
sometimes you go to a wedding you're
like you can clearly see you know that's
the family table that's you know the one
friend group table that's the other
friend group table yeah cause you always
have people you have to invite right
you're like yeah i have to invite them
but i know they're gonna they they're
gonna cause problems yeah yeah i put
them near other people
so we decided to do to do something a
little different uh without spoiling
who's
sits next to who we had a fun time being
like who who would get along with who
uh while not knowing each other too well
so we we had to think about you know
what kind of personalities would get on
so we didn't sit we didn't sit people
next to each other who they might
might be so familiar with you know not
too far away from just being completely
strangers but uh it was it was a fun
time just you know just kind of like
kind of like pairing people up and
pairing like friendship groups up and
just seeing like the absolute state of
some of the tables that we have planned
because we've basically just put all of
like the [ __ ] big characters on one
table oh no
um and yeah it's it's uh it's gonna be a
lot of fun just to see just to see if
you guys get along well with each other
because it's it's like as you said it's
like two friendship groups kind of
merging because i don't actually have so
much family like so much family coming
to my wedding it's actually like a small
wedding in comparison to other weddings
i've been to